et donc la décision que nous avons prise
c'est en effet un couvre feu un
couvre-feu qui va s'appliquer à la
région ile de france
vous le verrez que le virus circule très
activement et à plusieurs métropoles à
huit métropoles en plus de la région ile
de france
je les cite pour que ce soit clair pour
tout le monde
les métropoles j'ai des biens de
grenoble lille lyon aix marseille
montpellier rouen saint-etienne et
toulouse les l'ensemble des élus de ces
métropoles ont été appelés les préfet
mobilisés pour organiser les choses ce
couvre-feu il se fera entre 21h et 6h du
matin et il commencera à partir de ce
samedi 0 heure il durera combien de
temps écoutez il durera le gouvernement
est en mesure de le décider pour quatre
semaines
nous irons devant le parlement pour
pouvoir essayer de le prolonger jusqu'au
1er décembre